so the coffee company was at one of many
companies they hit you up oh yeah
they're always someone random they're
like hey I got a t-shirt that you know
coming in you know it says this and if
you people send me free stuff all the
time
but it's a lot of stuff like I can't
wear or I don't I just don't wear it and
I'm not like fungi anymore and they know
beveled this behind me okay but this
Fila a face I don't judge but because
it's like that's when you retain seconds
in my life no no it's not I haven't no
no no I haven't asked for any money or
nothing I don't know well that's what
you guys start doing dude yeah I need to
stop playing around
Oh asking for money yeah yeah yeah no I
haven't answered if I was like not over
to drink coffee so if they pay you
enough money you won't carry be like hey
these are these are these are cocaine is
half okay I slits are so big the vision
is clear I love free coasters or
something like that but how much there's
always things that don't need no one
like hey man you want some free protein
or something I don't know some free and
some clothes that look nice our t-shirts
they say stupid stuff but yeah whatever
does it make you start to do you have
preacher merch yeah I've merged nice
yeah I said after my shows I don't have
online I'm dumb I'm really dumb looks
like a toaster hey man you're just kind
of stepping into this new world right
like you're how many years removed from
from age 18
not even whoa actually my first audition
was in March 13th so it's been a year
and the holy [ __ ]
that is crazy that is the power of
[ __ ] since I'm being ready for the
moment you know I'm saying and and
backing it up with all the work that
you've been doing it and are doing and
then getting exposure like that
it's crazy she's [ __ ] bonkers how
many people watch that show well they
they we just we average 16 million
viewers I mean those are blossom numbers
you know I get crazy insane man it was
it definitely changed my life I mean it
was uh it was I didn't know I knew the
show it's big yeah that know how big it
was right it was it was uh I didn't
realize how many families family members
and friends I had either talked about
that how many years had you been doing
stand-up before you audition for the
show eight years eight years yeah so and
that's and that's always the thing I'm
sure you got this and it probably bugged
the crap out of you we were like oh man
overnight sensation you're like dude I
was putting in work yeah yeah did stuff
before then just get me off the street
yeah yeah I didn't just have this idea
like oh don't be a comic today yeah I
get the I could be a lot I mean I get
that lot and I used to hear um I see a
lot of stories about people that would
go on the show and they they hadn't done
it like that much they did like for
maybe a year or two and they blow up in
this with the headline then they can't
yeah yeah yeah so when I went there I
was uh for me I have been doing colleges
before and so I had been doing like an
hour on stage I mean wasn't good but I
mean was it was good it was deep I mean
it wasn't some everything's not good in
hindsight when you hear ya can you're
like how did they pay me to do that yeah
it was a good show for them you know
yeah so I mean I was yet so that a lot
of that happened but it was I was
prepared when I got when I heard the
show and I started going on the road I
was a tip a improv that's my first
weekend and it was a tip it was amazing
I heard you crushed there by the way oh
really you know game guy named Charles
Ingram yeah that's my home yeah yeah
that's a great way so that was your
first then taste of like alright let's
see how I draw after yes exposure and
then we did the pretty much the base pay
for a no-name headliner yeah just I mean
because people were like we don't know
what you've done right
yeah sure yes so we did that and then I
think we sold out every show but - oh
yeah that was during the show like I
only had went to the semi-finals I
didn't go to the live show semi excuse
me I didn't go to the I only went to the
second round I didn't go to lives semis
or the finals right so I went to two
rounds and we did we did a whole weekend
at two shows I didn't sell out
everything else is sold out which when
when I was taking picture with people
they like can't believe I'm meeting you
a person this way I think this is weird
for me yeah I'm here I'm $14 $14 a 67
cents in my bank account no that way I
didn't have enough I had a negative I
started making my money when I had merch
I couldn't put in my bank account to my
bank is it mom now I haven't back on the
west coast but I had a bank on East
Coast yeah and I couldn't put any money
in it so I had a whole bunch of cash
from merchandise but I wasn't a negative
from I had no money and I was like what
is that like how are you I mean say are
you asking them to give you like your
money up front so you can get your pole
there you just like I get all this food
to go from no I would well what I would
do that weekend I would borrow money
from like my mom or my brother and so
she was since she was send me some money
but then I would use the rest in cash
that made off a merchant but I mean I
made the money back after that weekend I
was fine now what kind of mercies you
have or do you had t-shirts and she's
mad enough teachers I had at wristbands
Wow the wristband said that's for live
comedy Bridget Lawson and I sold a map
to my show for whatever would anyone who
wanted to give I was like you can get
whatever you want to give oh you did the
I think was it Radiohead that sold an
album where it was just like hey
whatever you want to pay for really yeah
how'd I do really well for them oh okay
yeah I mean it was good for them cuz
some people they have obsessed fans
they're just like great I'll pay you $40
for this album it's like really you
could have paid one but okay I know
that's there's a lot of people that
really love you know yeah they'll be
like here's a bunch of money yeah I've
had people come to me and I'm sure you
have this - well they just give you
money after the show yeah that's weird
yeah some way I like I almost want to
feel insulted cuz sometimes they just
throw like $5 on the table it's like hey
I'm stupid yeah oh man get a Snickers
yeah how was how was I mean that whole
AGG experience
you can't nothing can really prep you
for that even if you've been doing
stand-up 20 years because that is just
like and you haven't gotten because that
was your first TV right like well I did
I mean yeah as my first major TV
everything I did before it really didn't
matter
yeah I did laughs oh I mean I mean
whatever all right so I did take overlap
see I did some other TV shows that was
you know I don't want to say I do like
the Carson Daly show yeah it's like I
didn't I didn't uh I've never I don't
know what people really watch that as
much yeah and you know maybe it doesn't
relate so much to comedy like when
people would watch Carson Daly show
they're not thinking like oh I wonder
who the next big comedian yeah yeah yeah
it was more of a music sheet for sure so
that's my first big thing yeah that's my
first big thing
what's the prep for that like I mean you
get the audition is it as crazy as they
make it look on TV where everyone's in
line and everyone's nervous and people
were talking [ __ ] people become know the
way they do it is they have they have
Scouts they have Scouts and then they
have the people that man is it's insane
so they have people you look for me like
someone looked for me they found me on
they went to Orlando there's like who's
the top ten comedians so yeah so they
asked the comedy club that they list the
top ten comedians they looked a ball
with us on YouTube they hit me up they
sent us some more footage so I sent him
some more footage and they were like I
would like you and this this and it was
promising all this and it was like yeah
you know we think you're gonna do well
you know we think you might you can do
well enough to get to the semi so
whatever you know and I was like
whatever you know I mean and cuz I had
done this it's not the first time I like
this format Got Talent okay no the first
time I did I went in there and I you
know they say they say all these things
are how good you can do but it leads is
up to you well I went in there are you
the guy who ate fire in season two yeah
[Laughter]
so no no I I did the first audition and
I did I just bombed I just
they will and I'll just I don't know it
was weird it was oh you know what
happened I don't know if I can say this
but there was like or whatever you need
you need people people want like there's
a guy on the on the show him that says
name but it's a guy on a show that I was
on the same season and he was amazing
like he was incredibly talented we
didn't have a story so you need a story
of someone that yeah different people
would be less Comic Standing
yeah boys yeah we're like if you go in
there cuz I did Last Comic Standing and
I just went on going like oh I'll just
be funny it's like ya know so you gotta
like wear shoes that you bought with
your money that's come in like this is
my last chance at show business or yeah
my mom hates me or I got negative $14
yeah yeah yeah like you gotta have that
it's like that Brent Morin bit when the
kid for like a British America's Got
Talent that comes out yeah he's like he
always gets choked up because there's
always some kid walks out and they're
like what's your name and he's like I
don't have a name you know I couldn't
immediately invested you know yeah when
I was on a GT I remember there was a
story where there was talking about me
being homeless right in LA and then a
friend's coming back to me because I'd
seen a clip delay guys I know you had to
lie to you know yeah you know and I was
like I didn't lie I just didn't say
anything when I was homeless doesn't you
brag about
guess who's sleeping in his car yeah
it's just it's not I would have to force
that out of conversation I'm great you
know just woke up I'm Street and you
know like it it's not something you
asked me all right it's not somebody
with appetite it's not something you
need to bring up find you we're all
struggling [ __ ] and no one's bringing it
up to you like a preacher you live in
anywhere yeah like that's how we start
the conversation you know hey preacher
you got one of those roofs burgers good
where your house in like no one's doing
that what is your door smell like okay
all right
so wait how did you is that it a
well-known thing that you were homeless
when you got out here a well-known thing
I mean anyone that watch HGTV they don't
yeah
but how I wasn't home with that long I
was almost like two weeks no excuse me I
was homeless like I was on the street on
the street for like two days
yeah but only yeah yeah boom some people
like two days is fine for me but what
happened was I was talking to talk to a
girl and then I tried to stay with her
she was like I could try to find no
place and I was like for sure I have
another place I did not have another
place yeah okay this is I feel like I
have to tell you so much yeah all right
so back to AG is so much okay so when I
first moved to LA I mu I didn't have a
place to stay I did is a bold move
yeah well I thought I did my mom said
she was gonna give me a hostel
yeah and for 22 days so I had 22 days
when I got there at the card bounced
apparently
oh so I had how your nothing a friend
why not stay with that friend like a
month and then I found a place on
Craigslist and I shared a room we have
$600 the share room in Park LaBrea with
a crackhead and this dude did every drug
I'm like bro you don't want to pick like
two drugs and maybe rotate
you mean like maybe two three yeah pick
all of them like a wacky windy way in a
[ __ ] you know I've been motivational
Monday yeah [ __ ] switch drug and a
wine Wednesday something like that you
know so he just he did every drug we he
was a my best crackhead he could yeah
you're talking about him he's hitting
you up going like hey that's my
girlfriend extra how nice so yeah
hey I'm doing the podcast right now okay
yeah all right all right talk to you
later
Levi it was a thing you're talking about
crackhead oh yeah this man was he was
made your girlfriend no I
he's a singer she is talented I do not
bringing the bold funny but this this uh
knew he was gay which is totally fine so
yeah I mean but he just he was my back
heads for the best crack yeah LeVar
Burton said that yeah but he was like he
was like weird like he would try to
convince me that I was gay you know me
like to be like gay I'm like no no no
I'm not not mean I think if your gaze
cool but I'm not gay he's like you
trying to tell me you've never looked at
another man and said they were track I
was like yeah I've seen cute babies I
don't have sex baby the way that I look
at the sandwich doesn't mean I want to
eat it out yeah so uh so he was crazy so
we ended up getting into it and I like I
like I'm not a violent person at all
like I'm not I think the last blast him
I got in a fight I was well I got in a
scuffle when I was like 23 but before
that I was 16 and it wasn't a fight I
just got beat up like it wasn't yet so
uh but there's a bunch of people I was
in a thing called Job Corps you know
that is yeah it's like jail for younger
people
yeah pretty much I was in job when I was
16 because I you went to jail no not a
guy's yeah but I didn't I wasn't doing
well in school because I'm in July right
so you can't move liable so I was like I
stopped no consistency man yeah exactly
so I ended up I ended up just stop
trying they denied I failed that I had
to go to like I guess like summer school
and then she's like you're going to Job
Corps so with the Job Corps like boot
camp or it's like it's like it's like
it's like for kids that usually get out
of jail and they need a restart gotcha
okay kids that on me
you know me me they sold drugs like it's
so like cocaine I remember I sold candy
that was my thing like hey preacher what
why are you here you're like well I
bounced around a lot yeah I know really
like I got a lot of jails houses it was
a C in social studies I was some crazy
stuff one dude there was taken you know
I mean like he was like it was the crazy
environment people get beat up all time
good jump they jumped me is what I'm
saying that's how I got beat ups when I
was six my flash backs about it was no
that was a quick beat yeah it was pretty
quick well what happened was it was it
started off as a joke what happened was
I was talking smack to everyone you know
I'm joking around I'm loud whatever your
comedy was a part of you from yeah yeah
always been that when I was seven I
figured out I was like I love making
people laugh because when I was seven I
was that okay I met with no this is bad
no track we'll go back to crack when I
was like when I was seven there's Asian
kid with him being age has nothing doing
store but he was though it does vary
when you're painting a picture on paint
Richard yeah that that ethnicity and
race exactement size and shape and color
it's not a matter yeah no it's not even
be be racing pictures Asian so here's
when it is [ __ ] up back when he had
his nunchucks a whip but when people
like you know I used to everybody that
would do that but it had nothing to
matter for the story be like man I was
at the park my friend Dave and he saw
these pigeons and he starts running at
these pigeons right and Dave's black and
he's running the pigeons and I'm like
the [ __ ] this day being black afternoon
well because then the pigeons are racist
exactly alright stay here when I walk
back cool with Jamal night you know so
that makes sense that's funny
so notice Asian kids on the swing yeah
he was swinging and I faked like he
kicked me and I just like flipped on the
bark doesn't it all I mean obvious for
my stylist oh but see now now it does
mean something that you said he was
Asian because I saw Crouching Tiger
Hidden Dragon that's believable you fly
backwards you like yeah kick hard
oh yeah so that's when I realized I like
Madiba left he was he was like he was
died he was like turning red he was
laughed so hard I did that for every
recess for like my four days knees like
you got a deal to some new recess bits
that's the best like go twos yeah it's
so funny you know spun it when I wasn't
a comedian I said repeat stories yeah
and I would like read these stories in
there what I would like shrim off the
fat and it's like stuff I don't even
know I won't do it and he says well your
open mics I mean I guess I guess you
don't think about it but like yeah yeah
I mean yeah I mean yeah you tell stories
yeah well I group of friends in lorry
like a parents or your friend's parents
like dinner or something and something
comes up yeah yeah so you stand up
though what was that a part of you
recognizing you makes people like make
you laugh and a common fear I was a huge
fan of comedy I mean I I just I just
like make people laugh I was you know
pretty hyper I was hyper and quiet I was
I was uh it was a mixture but I I was a
boy without talking before the Asian kid
make me laugh crack head oh yes so job
core job core oh yeah job well so I was
messing around with a bunch of you I was
joking around and what happened was they
all they had security like people were
that what they would go to school or
their job or for a trade and security
was a trade or carpentry like I want for
carpentry like I could I could build a
house like you know you yeah that's
pretty cool but oh they had a security
guard there but security is you know
they have at certain times they switch
off the actual grown security guards to
like the kids so there was a kid he was
like nothing like you know he was in on
it
so you know I was talking smack so they
bust in like we're in a dorm so it's
like a I promise a he's like eight of us
inside his room and they break down the
door and then they drag me off the bed
put the blanket on and they're supposed
to be fake hitting me
but they were fake hitting me like my
back was and that they was kicking me
punting to all his extra stuff and and
then yeah it was supposed to be for fun
so it's like I can't really be like they
beat me up I mean because it's like yeah
we're joking yeah just playing around
Wow so that's not guys that's how I got
beat up but I mean that is about it but
did you watch when you were comicview
you said you big fan of huge fan of
comedy what was the first time you've
ever seen
stand up on to your guys the first time
I ever seen Stan bond at me was come
with you I just watch it all time me I
just hate when they were remix it though
I'm like you're ruining the bit like
they would do a joke about like someone
would do a joke about lifts laughs yeah
and then they put like five flip flop
jokes back back and it's like any night
you're not making it look good
no you're not making original cuz you
got all these flip flop jokes and then
they would they would edit it and it
would make it super weird I don't know I
just didn't like that but I just I love
yes the in division meant to be in
you know yeah yeah it were so low who
were some of the people that were on
comic view at that time Gary Owen was on
comm of you I remember I remember him
doing a joke and they made him turn into
a Hulk and I was like you just made
enough fun
they made him turn green and they brew
like Ezreal no that's that the whole
joke is he is not a hole yeah exactly
like Kevin I think I've been Kevin are
is amazing that you know I love his few
uh his first few specials are I think
are incredible yeah and then as let his
last special I think he had like the TV
behind him whatever yeah and I was and I
was like it was kind of distracting from
the pyrotechnics you said like that all
the pyrotechnics yeah I know that word
means do you think about that I know I
know that but like I'm let's just say
let's say Brad didn't know what that
meant though like what do you what'd you
say to him fireworks I would oh yeah I
probably go with the boom boom boom
bright sky stuff yeah but I just went
when that happened it was kind of more
like I don't I just wanna watch but that
means but I just heard there's a TV he's
making to me I thought it was great I
thought it was uh you gotta definitely
got to step outside your comfort zone to
do stuff like that
and so the planet where they would
Stadium yeah that's got to be insane
right just like that's gotta be super
dope I mean have what's the most people
you ever performed in front of I did a
opened up one time and did a basketball
Stadium so that was 16,000 which was
just crazy that's bonkers
that's insane was it like this you you
you you say a joke and you hear a laugh
and then two seconds after the left
there's another laugh because the echo
from the people in the back that laugh
is just hitting you well it throws off
your timings you're like you're not used
to it that's like another skill level
then yeah it's a hole so the fact that
Kevin Hart's doing [ __ ] football
stadiums yeah I don't know these huge
just I don't understand where when he's
I remember him I'm very opposed not a
snapchat he's or his Instagram because
like I get to sleep y'all you got there
now figured and I should not know what
he was talking about yeah and I'm still
nowhere near as busy as kid hour at all
but I don't sleep yes you post that a
lot about I mean just finding
but it is I mean you get windows right
like you sleep on planes where do you
find the boys yeah see one place you're
eight yes I'm sleeping is lisanna it's
on a plane wait you want to do me a
favor you want to put on my Instagram
that'd be great yeah well and uh wait so
back to uh back to you fight in the
crack head okay so I'm not a violent
person so I threw him at the house like
cuz he came in drunk and he was like
yelling at me like you monkey in words
ladies or cookie piece of you ain't
glutton yeah burn is a burn cookie is a
racial slurs like I just think about the
burn cook it yeah yeah when I was like
Puerto Ricans so we just didn't hurt me
as much like I don't know I was like do
you know that's what they call you -
right yeah like so why people are so
raises we don't even care yeah that
we're being specific yeah general one
yeah you're this word it's like I'm from
Guatemala it's like so but he was just
really yeah I was trying to sleep and I
wasn't getting sleep at that time but
that was no it's all mics and be there
for hours and not get on stage and come
walk on the back side have vehicle and
where were you walking - I would walk to
the improv it taken about an hour and
out yet about an hour and you were
living where again I'm sorry I was
living blog for a maybe like an hour to
get to put you know yeah I'm gonna take
about an hour and a half some changes
get the Comedy Store but I would walk
everywhere how the great shape I got to
I got to the point where I got a I got a
skateboard and then I got upgrade from
skateboard to the bicycle yeah a man by
two wheels then then they stole my bike
so this is uber everywhere and then I
got a motorcycle now it's pretty cool
yo that that is a yeah that's a I get to
walk in holding a motorcycle helmet
which yeah we know Jerrod Carmichael
used to walk everywhere and he said he
would do most was writing while walking
yeah would you do the same thing or what
would you do on your walks maybe have an
hour to kill time what are you thinking
about
I would I would like I can't wait to get
a bike oh these scooters go what a life
yeah the most amount is crying
but you know know that was I would I
would like talk on the phone a lot like
the whole time mm-hmm I would talk on
the phone I've know one time I was
talking on the phone to this girl named
Zoe bad no talk to anymore I just gotta
say I could just I was talking on the
phone she won't even text me back no
sould on let me fact check this turns
out your life yes but her name was
Andrea she has a hunchback so I was on
the phone this lady has seen me and
started running from me and it was on it
was on my way to the improv okay she
goes running she has groceries his heels
on yeah and then because I think she
thinks I'm gonna Robert and so I get to
her she goes to get to a car she's
trying to get in I'm like man I'm not
gonna Robbie mm-hmm I'm a cop there's no
funny into this by the way that's what
she thought yeah she was like I'm not
gonna not gonna rob you did you say
that's exactly what a robber would say
you can build a house crappy burglar you
build it then you rob it all right okay
cracking oh man this is such a long
story all right don't be one of these
details okay I'm so ATD it's funny cuz
when I was a kid see there it goes they
try to put me on medication yeah and my
mom was like nah he'll grow out of it
and like that they bow for wrong cuz I
didn't grow out of me I grow into it
yeah but yeah now you know how to use it
exactly harness my power yes the power
of the adb yeah yeah so yeah can you
imagine a toned-down version of you it'd
be so not funny no it's already almost
funny now you don't mean like I'm just
squeaking back yeah so you're walking
open mics so yeah yeah so I came home I
got home around 1:30 2 o'clock and I get
home and I know I only sleep 3 hours cuz
I was working to LA Fitness I promised
someone I was gonna wake up earlier and
train them or whatever you were trainer
I wasn't a train I was a fitness Council
but I would go above beyond because they
if I was super nice to them and they
ended up signing it with me I mean
signing up training I get a bonus so you
hear the guy
what's the difference between a fitness
Council in a trike you welcome people in
mentor and you go nope I there's the
tours like the front desk god I do I do
that well I would tour people if I knew
there were a potential client gotcha
but sit-down consultation yeah and I
would be like hey this is where you're
messing up you need to work on this this
and this and this what are you thinking
yeah we're now I would say you know what
are you they'd be like I couldn't afford
it they say in the beginning they're not
write down a bunch of things they do and
like oh I'm times you get coffee a week
I'll get coffee like oh but you know
every day every morning go get coffee
that's five dollars five times seven
every day is 35 $35 for a training
session will give you natural energy
just working on me I just you know oh
you're good hold on I could go sign up
for a trainer thing someone said they
were spending money on that you got them
to like the crazy
dildos a money want me to give that up
you better get me a six-pack new dildos
every month
I really do for a living don't ask me
that I had someone to drink wine like
five bottles of wine a week or something
like that she's oh yeah all right so he
signed up Gerard Depardieu
nobody got it he's a French actor he
claims he drinks three bottles of wine a
day okay yo man you get that new
Depardieu album does this collaboration
with Drake it's crazy
what uh what's the real quick what is
the vibe like at the gym is it comical
is it like we're able to pull material
from a place like so much material yeah
I just have hole I just have multiple
videos let me record and people at the
gym working out that's awesome yeah I
used to do that all the time and I felt
bad because I'm just like I did I'm like
if you're gonna show up in public and
run backwards on a treadmill and then do
push-ups like next to the treadmill and
scream while you're saying I mean like
Yugi you're outside yeah and I mean look
I love that you do that but just as much
as you get to do that I get to I want to
show the world
damn mm yeah I did this I would I would
have record videos maybe it was fun man
I love the job that's the only job one
only jobs I loved it seems like cool
people any time I walk around like a gym
you see the staff like they're all
shooting the [ __ ] and chumming it up
it's right like Joe yeah I mean I dig it
we had some yeah it was super Cheers
I mean I would say yeah well it was a it
was it was a good job and III yeah I
don't know that's the only job you have
anyway yeah yeah I had I like after I
had that job I quit on a whim cuz I was
like I should just quit sure it's just a
mnemonic mansell tation you're like 7
times 5 if you get if you stop drinking
coffee you stop buying dildos you can
you know what [ __ ] it never gonna lose
that way I'm out of here now you know
people one of cuz people make the
biggest excuses that something I hated
about like there's a lot of people that
make these these excuses like oh the
only reason you're in shape is because
you work here it's like that excuse
would work if I was the most in-shape
person here like that then I'm not the
most important you know I mean like I
don't know people make us you I don't
have time like you don't you don't I
don't know you have you have time you
just want to do other [ __ ] that ackley
yeah I like those honest people that I
don't want to do it my guy well I can't
be honest yeah yeah no word but there's
like you know there's plenty of colors
in the outside yeah I wanna let the
weights but they're heavy
yeah so I mean it was just a great vibe
I love that job and it was pretty cool
as far as like you know it's a great job
to have when you're single you know like
it's gonna say man it's pretty cool yeah
you're working alongside I don't really
get the Explorer because I mean I met my
girlfriend there oh [ __ ] used to go
there gym then yeah you can't be like
because then she essentially be coming
in yeah we first started talking to and
so yeah it was pretty well now the whim
did that put pressure on you then like
you quit now you're like all right now I
need comedy to survive yeah I think a
lot of times at you people people will
have a safety net and you can't really
get too far when you're like kind of
holding on to yeah sharing behind you
so it's I think life is you know like a
cat like you you you back a cabin to a
corn it's gonna it doesn't it won't
attack you - you like Backman corn so
that's what I did I back myself into a
corner so the only way I can exceed is
about comics so I just started putting
out crazy videos on YouTube I started
trying to get on stage as much as
possible and then that's when um I mean
things started happening like I started
I went into Big Sky a comedy festival
with people are seeing your videos yeah
yeah yeah just getting
tossed around did you had a video that
went sim baby viral you know I mean it
was about it was like things people say
to comedians and I remember I went to a
festival and this is I remember that
video oh you remember it was yeah that
audio but oh I remember seeing that
video
Oh see so someone told me some comedians
that I mean it was really famous wrong
comedians yeah yeah they're like oh man
you're the guy who did the video of me
yeah so yeah it was just a bunch of
things that people say to comedians yeah
and yes so that would go and I did
another video when I was working at LA
Fitness where I was I just did a so far
gone challenge where it was like it was
it was a wrap on Monica's beat and I
just wrapped it but you rapped bunch of
girl and I was talking to Janine that
time and I did some super silly rap and
it went a blow it was amazing how you
never know yeah I've never known I'll
try so hard to create a video that just
such an intricate shoot when you're
always gonna go great yeah nothing
well here's me rapping over a harmonica
Merrill so there I was
I've literally I got home I was like I
was doing the challenge and I like wrote
it on the way home I wrote on the way
home and and then I said get your camera
get the camera hold my camera and then
she's like for what and I didn't even
tell her so I did the rap and then at
the end the rap up hold up a knife so so
I didn't tell her I was like rah
Depardieu
you know yeah yeah yeah except by saying
no no no so I I took the knife I just
said get the camera so she's like it's
kind of weird that you just say get a
knife yeah so I I so I do this rap and
then like that I post it and it's maybe
like it's maybe a day it was like 10,000
views and I was like wow that's crazy
the next day he was like 55,000 Wow
third day it was like a hundred thousand
views and it was insane they got mes
stopped I think it's like I stopped the
800,000 and the people were just hitting
you up I mean all right that's the first
like sense of any kind of Fame I feel
because I look oh my gosh I tried to
reply to everyone I couldn't it was
who's hitting you up tea teachers old
friends oh not them
no not a pen now it was just a bunch of
people I've never met it was a bunch of
people that this
cool video bro yeah yeah yeah and there
was a bunch of women I love you in like
you don't even know one knife on a girl
holding the camera you're like I love
you nothing weird is like I was brave
but a girl didn't they was like we don't
care there's a lot about you and here so
anyway crackheads so much racket
so we RC quit le fitness you're walking
open mics you're living a park blade
with this crackhead okay this is this is
what I'm still working LA Fitness so I
can throw him out the house Oh
the next day I find out whoa that night
went that night we found out that we
were we weren't legally living there so
the whoever we were subleasing from what
that wasn't their place so we had to
hope they had a no they like you gotta
leave by tomorrow in a way but I don't
even know that until I threw him out and
I was like Oh was this note oh we got to
be gone and so so I stayed with a girl
and then for like a day and this she's
like I could you leave and I'm like all
right and then I was didn't ever play
stay for a couple days and then after
that it was actually a girl talk to now
she was like could you is there any way
cuz she's a singer and she she couldn't
she has this thing which if she doesn't
know you like that and this is us knew
she can't sleep so she wasn't sleeping
she was a court album so she was like is
there any way that you can find you know
I mean and I was like yeah I said I got
plenty of places yeah I didn't have a
place so I wouldn't stayed on the street
for a couple of days and then I didn't
feel like where do you sleep I slept I
will put all my stuff in there I
finished closet so I had all my stuff in
there and then i'ma go to Mike and then
I would I would I would fall asleep I've
been one time I felt even like the alley
of like in Beverly Hills not in super
nice Beverly Hills but like that yeah
near Fairfax
okay so the edge so like yeah just like
there or go to a park and I will walk
around a lot and a lot of times I would
mess me up because I'll be falling
asleep during work and I get in trouble
and they're like why are you falling
sleeping I can't be like oh I'm homeless
yeah yeah so I would fall asleep and I
was sleeping or I was sleep during break
so a lot of times I mean Mike's I
wouldn't get home till like two o'clock
anyway yeah so I mean I would just I
would open mic and then I would go
I would go to work sometimes I would
sleep in the locker room yeah we're just
yelling in more like a shower no and
just no just laid out on the bed no
where people lay their booty the bare
booty yeah right there right there so
nobody ever uh no you ever feel
comfortable to a doll cuz you're so
likable like no that's a comma granny
why not no I just didn't want to do that
right I don't yeah way too much pride
and I just don't figure it out right
yeah I'll figure it out I know it's
gonna be fun I always even sad or
anything like I was like I'll be fine
like I said were the first of all homes
I was homeless when I was important and
I was doing the same thing I was just I
mean I would hang out with comedians
yeah and then they'll you wanna come
over and yeah and I was just play video
games with them or talk write jokes now
just yeah I don't even write even know
yeah you know and or I was just hanging
out with women and that's what and
that's what I did that's what I'm saying
I was only on street for two days that
was like I'm tired of this cuz I really
like the girls talk to ya but I was like
I'm not I can't say where else yeah so
hang back feel streets off right so I
just started you know hanging out I was
doing that and then I went to up got to
a point where I found the place on
Craigslist it was a beauty shop and I
stayed at I stayed inside the beauty
shop which they were like you can't use
the business you know I mean I thought
you trying to a business here I was like
nah
and then I end up getting the place with
the guy who has the most viewed episode
on almost got away with it
wait what's it trying to think you know
when you people that do crime yeah
I mean almost got away with it never
show as long why I end up being
roommates with him yeah here's the most
viewed episode so what he did he shot
his cousin in the faces like you do yeah
yeah Tuesday so he shot he shot his
cousin in the face yeah and he pretty
much started like you know video privacy
like movie Pirates like he pretty much
he just started but he like made it
popular
okay he went to jail for that and for
like I don't like tenure I know he got
out and this man is he's he's crazy he
know he great I think he's okay with
hearing you say that yeah but yeah he's
pretty sure if you if you were on that
show man there's a good chance yes
what do you almost get away with the
piracy so even go to jail I mean he
would that he didn't go to jail for his
shooting his cousin the face less
American you won't but it doesn't mean
that so maybe okay so he shot his cousin
he didn't die so fine yeah someone let's
make sure they don't die very care so he
shot us cuz in the face and then he what
the jail piracy but that was cuz he did
like I don't know how how the system
works but once you do a crime like shoot
someone in the face yeah they do another
crime if that's a bad level apparently
then you get more time in jail I don't
know how it works isn't that called like
double jeopardy or something so now that
that was a movie starring jean-claude
Van Damme sure Dennis Rodman sure name
no double jeopardy was Ashley Judd
that's where you can't be tried twice
for the same crime that's what it is it
was something with Ashley
oh I thought you were definitely trying
to be funny no I wasn't that bonus so
yeah okay yeah so that's what happened
you got like yeah he did that so I
didn't move it in with my my lady of the
million by currently and so we and then
yeah we yeah and then do you hear and
then that's when you hear about
America's Got Talent
no I heard from America's Got Talent
when I feel like it I heard when I was
living yeah probably yeah prime time
when I was living when I moved back in
when I moved with my lady okay they
heard they hit me up way before way
before and cuz they like I said they
have Scouts and then they have people
that actually at the girl don't want a
year before we was on she was in line I
mean so I mean it's not like they only
find that that's not like for sure yeah
so everyone that's that auditions they
audition you had audition for the
producers then you get you passed that
one you another audition they do another
one and then you get Simon yeah you
don't just walk in it's not inside it's
there they don't they probably do like
maybe three out to people and yeah so
that's Lots that's why you moved from
Orlando to LA it was for got town or no
don't start just moved and it when
you're going no no but so when you were
sending them more footage and stuff is
this is that during the time when you're
bouncing around from place to place yeah
Wow yeah is it funny how the universe
works like that once you settle down and
a consistent place to live then yeah
then that's when the opportunity kind of
yes you didn't have to focus so hard I'm
like where the [ __ ] am I gonna sleep
tonight yeah that's true you know what
if you were going through all those
additions and while you were you know
walking around sleeping in LA Fitness I
mean I would've been [ __ ] crazy I
mean you just were but like yeah but the
thing was this like I didn't know how
serious it was cuz like that me a GT was
like Oh what you know you know you were
gonna if you do well or do this joke and
if you if we did they like you well you
can you can audition from these
producers and then you know there's just
so much it's so complex like yeah I just
didn't think it was that serious because
I have people to hit me up hey man I can
put you on this show well I can do this
for you whatever I didn't actually
believe it I had been on go ahead yeah I
was gonna say but by the time you got to
Simon for that quote-unquote first
audition are you even like are you just
numb to the whole thing or are you
actually nervous at that but when I
started recording yeah that's what I was
like this is cool I thought that was
cool but I didn't I wasn't like I'm in
this yeah until it aired really until it
aired I was like oh this is for real
you know me cause it's like I've had
friends that did the audition and they
they know they've done multiple
auditions in front of producers yeah and
then they they get they do die just for
an assignment they record it they get
passed and then they don't get aired
yeah I've heard about you know it sucks
yeah so you're like here we go
I did I did I got no exes I never exact
I'm good and they just don't get here
and they're probably telling their
friends and family yeah quad I've had
people do yet like there was a comedian
that he had all those people his friends
and family come together and they were
watching they were like oh yeah we cut
it
that's the producer just hit about last
night oh yeah by the waist you're not on
this episode that's more almost
devastating than being on the show and
and getting cut oh yeah yeah wait we as
we were I mean didn't I also want to
bring something up because I watched
your first audition and for an
assignment yeah curse you brush you
brush so hard and then Simon does
something I
I almost never see him do this where he
goes hey do more yeah do another joke
and that wasn't part of this script oh I
mean there was no there is no script
yeah they you have another joke planning
I was like yeah you know we comedians
yeah I was like I'm doing this joke of
that joke and they was like dude no
joking I'm like this joke yeah I mean it
was not that they made it seem like I
was more nervous but I wasn't expecting
it I was like what
but yeah I wasn't I wasn't the most
nervous I've ever been was the first
marijuana stage and right before the
first audition but as soon as I got on
stage I was like it's my world then
you're back home yeah amazing back in
charge yeah what just be just what the I
mean because obviously there's cameras
and there's people talking with a
loudspeaker right like we're going and
we're starting in five or what there's
all these other factors but you're just
throwing that out and once you get crowd
laughs you just like okay I know this is
yeah I've been doing this yeah I'll
think before I get on stage I'm like
about the bomb about the bomb look it's
crap about the bomb negging that first
lap I'm like I'm good you know I mean
later the judges you just plain to the
crowd or just like oh I didn't I didn't
know I was looking I was looking uh I
don't know I was looking around I don't
know it was weird it was really weak
that's at that point that was the most
people I've ever performed for it was
2,000 people yeah so before this is
different and it's the same thing when
you do will you do a joke and you gotta
wait yeah it's not no 16,000 oh that was
one time dude yeah and yes I bombed so
how did you really well I mean it was
just like daytime before he went on at
night and when he Cummings went after me
and it was just like not of it was the
Red Rocks in Colorado and it was just
like daytime it was kind of raining I
was trying to do crowd work with a
security guy up front like right out of
the got remember I got two jokes that
got like good laughs and then the rest
people were just still settling in it
was like before the show really started
yeah it was not people weren't there for
that or not pay attention to that it was
not fun yeah it's different during their
in America a GTI wouldn't open up for
boys the man that I did my shut the [ __ ]
up why didn't you just come in like a
before before we start I would have a
boy spin one time he was so dope what
was the venue where was it goes there
the fairgrounds there like it was like
7,000 people now is that like is that a
situation where whenever you're opening
up for bands
as a comic I always fear that because
the people aren't there like for comedy
so we're always amazing yeah okay so
there's a date so they were ice I did do
I did do I want to say because you did
16 right yeah that was the biggest ever
I think I did I want to say it was 15 is
that the growth yeah the way that work
that's huge really
but I mean but this is things so you got
you do what you do a basketball Stadium
yeah it's like you're in the middle or
like it might be cut I don't know how
yeah yeah yeah so it's nice I mean it's
like but the Grove it was just outside
so that I felt like I was just bombed
the whole time I felt like a bombing all
the time and I was like why you couldn't
hear you can't hear the laughs it was no
yeah there's no there's no acoustic I
didn't hear anyway I thought a bomb yeah
gotta say it like that was great I'm
like yeah it's weird there there's a
there's a place in the Bay Area called
the shoreline amphitheater and it holds
like I don't know how many holds like 20
yeah it's it's a lot yeah and but it's
outdoors that but there's this huge tent
and so I've done stand-up there and the
laughs literally go they hit the tent
which goes to the back of the stage so
you hear it behind the stage like
backstage you hear it on stage you think
you're bombing and then you get offstage
and ones like [ __ ] dude oh yeah you're
like I thought I I thought I just ate
[ __ ] for 12 minutes
like it also for stand up on a GT it's
to me the most unnatural starts because
we'll we come out you shoot the [ __ ] a
little bit um and which you could tell
they loved you right away like have you
always been like I don't know I had your
easy to make friends like likeable
people always like drawn to you is that
I am i I think I can make friends
socially I have been super comfortable I
wasn't like I mean I was just weird I'm
just me you know like I was I think I
was unapologetic me you know me so I is
some people like me and some people
think I'm annoying yeah I mean like it
so this is just as Who I am but I mean
III didn't I wasn't like super popular
like it when I was in high school at
having friends so I would like at
lunchtime I would walk to the store and
walk back that haven't want to sit with
oh yeah why not I was fake black I was I
just like walk it just like exercise you
know I gotta go get this fancy lunch
such that let's down the street you're
asking that cardboard pizza no I'm going
down to get some fancy French food yeah
yeah wait why why no friends well if
you're bouncing around new schools right
and just yeah yeah I mean the first year
I ever went to a full school I'm in
school for a year was I was 13 and was
an organ she it was a full year and then
I had the same thing happen in ninth
grade what's this thing but seventh
grade I went to three of the school's
sixth grade three different schools
fifth grade three of the school's
military family nah what kind like the
military okay kind of similar but nice
[Music]
that happened once innovate like I broke
my mom in like you know the ground like
a cat that's like seven yeah I mean it
was I don't know why we moved around lat
your folks give you that type I mean
like just your attitude your mind says
so like people can really you know you
obviously had to be around people or
have people in your life that kind of
you know gave you little pep talks or
did you should observe from people
around you like to develop into who you
are yeah I mean my mom is just really
she's like me she's like me she's a
little more [ __ ] I'll figure it out
yeah yeah well I mean the reason okay so
the reason I don't know why we moved so
I don't know yeah I think my mom just
didn't never said oh but I mean I just I
took a lot from my mom she's super
creative she's really uh she's uh she
just she just hurt you know and you and
she came out for something and she was
on America she came out yeah yeah that
was pretty dope that's prison my senior
years no [ __ ] yeah yeah so when eight
when I seen her they he made sure I did
not see her till then oh [ __ ] I remember
I was talking to Mike Young when the
contestants talked to him I'm like yeah
man you know that I died and he was
looking weird
and he started backing away I was like
what what's going on
and then my mom started running up and
oh my god I was trying not to cry oh no
like I should have cried I would've got
the bus that that's that I mean god
that's that's such a crazy moment and
then like because you're having this
real human moment yeah and you're also
probably somewhere in the back your head
going like wait a minute they're
recording this I'm on TV be kept like
yeah yeah what'd you say yeah what'd you
do like that that's got that's gotta be
just insane oh no I it was great I mean
special cuz my mom she's been my biggest
supporter she was there the first time I
went onstage she was more than it I was
so scared to go onstage first time that
they called the next person that took so
long to go onstage
really and then my mom was in the back
she's like no you're right here this is
gonna be going great now first time
going onstage your mom sticking up for
you that's good so bad so bad is there
what you want to go back on after you
bomb the first thought I killed I got in
the car
so mom was like yeah I did good didn't I
she's like you was you did okay I was
like you don't even try to lie to me she
kept the real weak ever real she's like
was okay like you got some laugh but
from this part like secret just breaking
it down right here you think it's great
are there any comedians from the show I
can prior years that tried to like reach
out and give you advice or yeah man Tom
Cobb Tom Cotter yeah he's really really
breeze out and helped me out that's
great he's good guy he's funny he's uh
he jokes per second i per and that's I
mean that's so great when you're got
that style for the show because yeah I
mean great cuz on a GT how long's your
set formats three minutes yet non I
maybe two in two minutes it's supposed
to be a it's supposed to be 90 seconds
but they let you go is too crazy yeah I
mean like how do you I don't know I mean
for the store open mic I used to do it
was three minutes yeah and that to me
was just like so difficult to pack in
and I was try to pack in more joeys yeah
that's the other people do like one long
thing and I was like oh maybe that's the
route but then yeah yeah you just you
want to get more laughs per minute but
then it's what
is kind of your your preference your
strategy well I mean I'm mopping my
style is kind of set up for a show like
that yeah yeah means so I have a lot of
I have a lot of jokes per minute I'm
super silly really immature so the kids
like me physical I'm just harmless big
for TV yeah yeah yeah I'm like this
harmless black guy I think I was just
looking for I think I don't look for a
woman this season you know I mean so I
mean but I think I think you know cuz
there's not one we named another black
me enough America's Got Talent
yeah yeah well Mel B was funny sometimes
I don't know I like how many on nickname
mechanic like me are like he's the host
well no I'm just saying that good
because I tried out for a wild about it
I even tweeted him I was like I'm fat
come on he's like now respond Black
Edition for a while now yeah yeah you're
a no brainer yeah I'm an addict
yeah are the opportunities now just like
I don't matter are you are you you know
in a position where you can kind of
expect well for stand up for sure right
like you're getting booked just through
the roof yeah yeah well yeah I mean I'm
on the road every weekend I'm exhausted
do you love it I love it man I love it
I'd seems like you got a schedule down
oh yeah yeah I'm starting to get it down
to like I'm getting my sleep down I'm
getting my I just need to be I'm getting
everything figured out now it's amazing
that and and you're doing it you're and
you're still doing YouTube videos you're
you're cooking cooking [ __ ] musical -
what are these pushes some songs on what
son you story oh yeah I got some songs
on Spotify now yeah dude yeah one of
them up yeah you don't have Spotify I
know I just what do you use hand or oh
that's crazy man
that's it I'm good with it but actually
I wish I was I wish I was like that but
now I discover all these songs and I
listen to all these songs yeah there's
like so much too much
it's amazing cuz just like we're we we
grew up in a time where the radio
station just told you what you had to
lay hey listen to this man I'm recording
on a cassette tape has songs on the
radio
I remember that Taylor so I could play
it back and now it's just like you can
discover so much good music alright so
[Music]
[Laughter]
doing the backups yeah yeah yeah that's
not before yeah I mean I guess I found
that song I mean [ __ ] in the shower yeah
[Laughter]
down the drain why do you have those
pipes
what are those hard yeah I mean yet
musical theater back on you just can't
sing that well I mean it's not pretty
good to me okay
it was alright I mean I can I can do I'm
one of those singers that I can do that
and you were like oh you could sing but
if you like if you like do some acapella
right now I'm like nah they do bad so is
there like a lot of post production on
that yeah but my girlfriend yeah well I
had this song for like probably like
four years before I met her I got a
recorded I can't get out of my [ __ ]
time see and I had it yeah I had another
there's another song called walking him
underwear I just thought of what I was
walking by the way sure and I posted it
and that's I post I posted it like two
years before I met her and then she
she's seen it and she comments it she's
like okay you could sing and then like
we made this song like six months later
after she said it was it's also great
because like you're I mean taking
advantage of like the the following
that's coming at you and like I'm you
already creating content but it's like
it's one of the things that you see that
really can't make a difference is like
yeah putting [ __ ] up consistently and
like Brad and I are always trying to do
more but it's just like a I don't think
to is like and sometimes I I you know I
used this as an excuse role Mike well
yeah if I had [ __ ] hundreds of
thousands yeah to do it that I'd be
doing it but it's like yeah but maybe
like you gotta be doing it to get there
but like I know and I said you know it's
crazy
I said make those excuses like if I had
money I'd be doing all this yeah and I
got money now and I'm like but what
instruments do y'all play a triangle
clarinet in the guitar okay literally
play guitar clarinet was three years and
I stopped in seventh grade so I just say
that because because it sounds cool
nope I don't know why just clear you say
to play a clarinet sounds okay I don't
know so I'm saying is you play I mean
usually I feel like every rapper
ambereen yeah okay these solitary mean
spoons okay I think I think as a dwarf I
could tell people I pay I play a pan
flute and they'd be like yeah that makes
a lot of sense so funny that I remember
when I was talking to play you and Zelda
yeah telling me how used to get mistaken
for the guy for Game of Thrones yeah I
used to be okay with it
yeah start making a name for yourself
yeah then you got mad and now there's no
breath now I go I go see infinity war
and spoilers not really okay okay I
won't tell me and I won't tell have you
seen it yes okay but I was then you then
you know I I got to go back
oh really yeah man like I remember it
ended and I was just like ah
wait what if you say wait what out loud
to yourself you got to go back for
seconds why did you go that hat well I
says the superheroes are flying around
you go huh it was unbelievable I mean
what I remember was phenomenal like that
it's all gonna love it it's also I'm not
a big superhero movie guy I love the
Iron Man's Deadpool I love but like I
haven't seen any the new Wolverines the
new captain Rigas
but this was unbelievable you know that
you know that it's all the rage that's a
known fact that much point about it no
no no no I know I know no Batman sinner
right that was my one gripe being like
no Batman there's Maddie for walking I
was like no Batman turn around
like he's not supposed Justice League
was there infinity war right yeah a bad
like but like now are you are you gonna
be when these guys where you try to like
Donald Glover right now has like he's
got childish gambino he's got the
comedies got the acting like are you
trying to get in all these different
areas
I would love to many I think he's a
incredible example I think it's amazing
he's like the modern Jamie Foxx's ooh
yeah dude he does everything well but
yeah I feel like I can but it's like my
my my measurements be off I feel like
it'd be so bad that's what they said
it's it's like you know how like you
play the guitar
yeah with last night you played mmm we
could go okay so how'd you feel great
you played right now oh not great yeah
this is like before that week was
probably three months see ya yeah see I
was like yeah that's how I feel good
building back in Rob bill my mama like I
came back and then uh she had me built
she just had me build everything like I
built the chairs
I built it I built her another room for
like a I was like I do love me or do you
just want me to use happy building all
this bad cheap labor now at some point
when you were on the streets like and
you had this construction background did
you ever think like if I could just on a
couple bucks a couple pop-tarts if I'm
gonna get enough cans staple gun
everything else I was like I'm just
gonna go to someone's house that's great
uh the road do you you love hotels do
you like what about the whole experience
is writing on the road a lot to and I'm
for somebody who's just jumping into it
like I'm so curious like what about it
are you I mean obviously like you're
packing your shows out so that's [ __ ]
great cuz nobody gets to do that right
out of the gate you know I'm saying yeah
it's pretty weird I mean it's it's it's
it's cool but it's like now I gotta
write you don't mean yeah I gotta think
of another hour yep and I thought of new
thirty minutes and it's really it's
really hard I mean cuz you think you
this week this is your mindset you're
like oh I'm headlining I'm doing Howard
I just think of plenty of new jokes and
then you're not thinking the features in
front of you trying to short like when I
have feature I was like my mind says
like I'm gonna make this headline of
work yeah yeah that's my that was my me
I don't get I don't know people some
people think it's me no way that's every
feature mindset and I think it should be
yeah that's my idea so I kind of forgot
that yeah when I first started going on
tour like I remember some do some do
opened up for me hey been doing it for
like 15 years and so you got so and he
was and he was like yeah he's like oh 17
he was 17 years and it was in whim so it
was he's been doing in 17 years
he was a funny cat but he he just
watched someone that had been doing it
half the amount of tyre and blew up yeah
yeah he's like I'm featuring for you so
he he was good he went it was a lot of
uh so it's a lot of times I can't try as
many new jokes out especially when I
didn't even like my hour to begin with
you don't mean cuz you gotta kill yeah
that cuz you the last thing you want is
the headliner cuz as as the feature you
want the people to walk out that place
going man that that middle guy should
have been headlining yeah and as a
headliner that's the last thought you
want that yeah so I mean it was hard to
think of you know newer jokes when I'm
trying to do the cooking show and I'm
writing these stupid songs why that
cooking show Rhett's I'm sorry I cut
Brad off from that but why the cooking
show
what spawn that well the reason I
started doing a cooking show is because
my mom wouldn't know how to make a
protein shake a natural protein shake
yeah cuz you're vegan right I'm a V yeah
which I was a big when I start I was
vegetarian start by the way props first
bill in the whole podcast with you not
saying you're vegan open up how you
doing I'm a vegan I'm going great we
don't do that those vegans I know no
wait this is what happens y'all ask us a
question y'all offer us hey you want
some Eminem's now I got chocolate in
there I'm a vegan are you doing what you
couldn't wait to tell us you you ask us
questions that lead us up there as
telling you they were vegan and then you
just stop on us for saying it's so
annoying
I hate
this burger I can I'm diggin oh it's
only been three minutes let's say you
know we don't care because we're more
perturbed that you didn't bring a boys 2
men so you taught her how to do that and
then what you made it and I'm not a
crazy vegan by the way I'm not like a
I'm mad like what crazy if you can say
by the way but no but no yeah no yeah
wait what do you mean by that though
like what are you like like you're not
wearing a meat is murder shirt yeah I
went to I wanted Peter cuz they found I
was a vegan
yeah and they invited me over now so
yeah I mean I don't really know much
about Peter I know they're vegan company
yeah yeah and so I went up there and
they gave me like a whole bunch of free
merchandise and they gives a tour do
stuff and then and then I posted on my
Instagram that people just flooded my
bed they were like yeah did this and
that and that and that and then the
shirts they gave me it was like first
murder and it was like blood all over
the shirt now I'm like I'm not a really
a Peter than ham yeah that guy like I'm
not and I if you eat meat I mean you eat
meat like I'm not a meat for years I'm
not trying to I'm not trying to say that
you all are bad people for yeah I mean
you already know that for me I feel I
just feel bad yeah but I mean as this is
what I mean I'm not I'm not a crazy
thing I was that I was doing show it on
like Fox Studios or some like that right
and then they had this whole convention
it was like it was like I don't know
it's super nice they had all these
everywhere everyone has stands and
drinks stands food stands and like pet
stands and and a dog licking people it
was weird then it had a goat yogurt and
so there's yoga yoga go to yoga go
yogurt looked like the goat stands on
their back where they're doing yoga
poses unbelievable it's insane but this
is what I mean so there's a guy was like
is a yoga it since the goat enjoying
that like now and then some girls like I
think he's enjoying it like them saying
how do you know the goats doing downward
dog isn't that [ __ ] up to you hahaha
so what I'm saying is I don't think I'm
pretty sure the go-to spot like it
if um you're giving it treats to stand
on people's back if you gave me ice
cream to walk on people like I'm gonna
that's that's great I'm gonna love it so
I'm not like that like if you're I'm not
that not a vegan I just don't like an
ice cream though like you already know
there's almond milk or something I don't
know okay so make these videos you send
me your mom
oh yeah and she's like I'm funny you
should do more of those or what oh I
made the video for my mom I sent it to
her they should like can you break it
down I'll break it down when I start to
break it down I was like I'll just put
post-it on my page yeah and I did it and
it did really well so I'll keep doing it
so I did a few more and then it started
picking up and started doing really
really good and I did a veggie burger
and that's what really like kind of blue
veggie burger the really popular ones a
veggie burger mac cheese and fried
chicken
being a fried chicken damn excuse me
how's making mac and cheese it's amazing
man takes exactly Mike it's so easy so
what you do is you take two carrots you
take a yellow potato you take two
carrots you take a yellow skin I feel
like I don't care I want to hear how you
[Laughter]
make mac and cheese to carrots I'm out
before a quarter moccasin okay so you
take you skin it you boil you cut them
up boil it yeah do you have a pair of
Uggs
[Laughter]
the taker let it boil do some goat yoga
yeah and a little bit garlic powder and
then a table a tablespoon of olive oil
and they you mix it in together in the
nest cheese great now now that now
that's not cheese but
Digga cheese very good she's cheese
invitation by the way that's not Jesus
or at least yeah it is right why yeah
because cheese's has cancer is a
carcinogen Namie cheese's I mean this is
my thing about vegan meta cheese not for
like ethical reasons but if you after
you eat it you feel good like you feel
like you mac and cheese you left that is
the thing that whenever I go to like a
veggie grill or I alright go to tender
greens and step salad or something like
[ __ ] I really do feel good yeah yeah
yeah yeah like I get mad how good I feel
yeah I'm like it so this is how I dance
that's how I should be but if you told
me I was gonna be a vegan in two years
three years ago I wouldn't have been
like that [ __ ] up Oh for real yeah I
mean the route yeah I was not I hate a
person with the right seasoning I did
not care at all cayenne pepper like if
you if you if you literally I'm not even
making such beauty you fed me a plate
and you're like that was a human named
John I'd have been like well John is
gone I don't think I got the ride but
that did you know pretty good but well
why'd you start cuz that a dog had a dog
I like said my dog was like eighty my
dog you know wow thanks a smarter dogs
pick the smartest are they really yeah
they're super smart
there's is that Brad does that mean does
that mean that they're because they're
smart the smartest out of those three
that they're the most cognizant of like
we're getting [ __ ] chopped up oh they
know Bach man oh so delicious they're so
smart
there's way smarter than dogs have you
had a pork belly sandwich why haven't
what if I gave them if I gave something
up or pork which I made okay I love
right out yeah I'm down it's just people
don't like that you don't like to take
some pig if I just gave you some pigs
important you would be like this is
stupid but you like the seasoning in
texture so jackfruit has the same
texture as a poor pork so will you take
the jackfruit and you just put the
barbecue I mean you make it a certain
way but you put the season on it it's it
takes if you would not know the
difference between a pulled-pork
vegan sandwich or regular pulled pork
sandwich it's texture season of
challenge accepted okay I have to cook
jackfruit yes jackfruit jackfruit Lisa
cousin the pineapples I mean it's just
you take that
it looks exactly like you trim it up and
you tear it like a pool port I wanted to
say this challenge just because I want
to eat a pulled pork sandwich should
come over in the preacher cook is a
vegan meal and videotape this always
happens you gotta be good Oh what's cool
about let me destroy you like 30 minutes
did your your cut but I'm jealous
I'm waiting on Brett we're breaking you
down because you're better Brad told me
it said hurry yeah I had hernia surgery
that because you're vegan you know if
you had a with meat what happened was I
was I was in a gym but what happened was
I just kept I was on a road and I
wouldn't sleep mm-hmm like I probably
average like four hours sleep because
you ride in the height of the show like
what's contributing to your lack of
exhaustion because I'm doing too much
your minds racing I'm doing my mouth
yeah it's so like the cooking episodes
so I write those out I got fine I got to
find recipes now can't I want to just
look one recipe up I look like ten
recipes up and then I come I try out a
bunch of them and I was like okay I like
this one the most and then I'm like I
take that and I write okay a few jokes
for that recipe
they're not gonna court it and you know
my girlfriend she's available she
recorded and then I edit it anything
tastes like ours it does it takes out
everything that comes together and
editing exactly it'll take like it take
like five six hours so I'll edit it and
then I'll post it and that's still me
doing social media me doing other things
besides cooking with you know me and and
doing stand-up and just living your life
yeah live yeah yeah so I I don't there's
not enough time in the day yeah so I I
would I would not I wouldn't work out as
much and I wouldn't get any sleep so I'm
not working out not get any sleep and I
try to lift the same when I was lifting
you know but I think like I don't know
like what I was what I was doing when I
was not as busy yeah and then I try to
go heavy I think was it like it was that
like 295 or something like that and then
it was people talking smack to me and I
was like yeah he go and then I did it
and I couldn't hit it and my my
I was like take it take it cuz I'm
scared I'm getting her name and then and
then I had heard you had two hernias now
when she first doctor and they were like
no miss dud
no you're good but it was it was a
friend of a doctor okay yeah we saw was
like so so he felt like he could
diagnose you yeah he's like no I mean it
was a friend okay I had a friend that
works at a hernia surgery office
so he didn't I wasn't paying so he
didn't care yeah yeah really bad reviews
but he was like nah nothing wrong I was
like Riddick's my belly but it's kind of
flopping around that normally like you
know a belly button yeah yeah yeah
genetics oh my god happy happier next 26
years breath yeah and so I went and I
went to a nut I performed and so dumb
and all these shows and then I went to
the doctor when I got back in town like
three weeks later yeah and this nurse
was like you gotta hurt him the nurse
then the doctor came was like oh you got
to hurry and then they did the surgery
and I had to have I mean if you see my
act I'm incredibly physical yeah yeah
yeah I had to have my girlfriend act out
my jokes
on stage with you yeah yeah yeah so I
would I would do my I would do my jokes
yeah and then the the there's a couple
of jokes that they wanted on a GT that
were too physical for me so I would like
I'd be like janae and then I was she
would come base believe they laughed
because it was her right and you're
commenting on her well a lot of people
are and a lot of people I mean can
deftly be inspired by your story I'm
sure you getting types of comments and
messages to its big man way awesome man
Android Beam dude you came from being
homeless in parks yeah yeah but that's
but this don't nobody say I'm a good
dude okay so what's up yeah I want you
to be like oh wait you know alright five
years when someone posts a text
conversation never said I was a good guy
yeah
I'm okay something about you and a goat
we don't know about
yeah gonna pop up later go to yoga I
told you I love animals so much I don't
I don't eat them well I do but not in
that but there are a lot to enjoy it I'm
still stuck on goat yoga I'm sorry I
know it's really funny it's really funny
oh there's a band they're really good
balance
yeah that's pretty good they run on
mountains so you even rocks oh yeah
they're good at but like huette who had
that idea and were there other animals
that they tried before go they're like
alright now we're gonna try Jubal yoga
no but all of a sudden someone's like
where's the gerbil well people have
people have so many chances to see you
they can see you live on the road doing
your act they could subscribe your
YouTube channel yeah watch it cook why
don't you do the watch you watch it work
out watching post sketches yeah it's
your loss on Instagram Twitter all that
right yeah everything's a preacher
Lawson yeah website preacher Lawson comp
yeah that thankfully there's not a
preacher Lawson time yeah yeah there was
when I first started doing stamp there's
a preacher man but I don't know he's at
right now I took his name yeah he's like
going on godaddy.com like and funny
preacher take it damn it
and that's not a stage name that's your
real name it's not a stage name and it's
not my birth name gosh when I was two
weeks old my mom was at a gospel
conference yeah and she was a bunch of
people that uh that never spoke to her
was like what'd he get oh he gonna be a
preacher he'll be a pastor so for fun
she was like i'ma start calling you
preacher I don't know what I was doing
to give that impression I was a preacher
at two weeks old cloud I could say can I
get away
I'm a Baptist I don't know why changes
mom's milking the wine but that that's
amazing our fans at our fans have to go
check you out yes go check me oh I
appreciate you you've had you've had
such a great time listen to the man go
see him go support them and share share
weird ass vegan recipes yeah bring me to
a show he'll just say vegan recipes you
can't just say that no hey vegan so much
I think you should hate me I didn't
think you liked my dupatta but you had
better have you had a traditional vegan
meal like a [ __ ] ice yeah they got
that well they got a they got a Mexican
restaurant down here called a gracias
Madre and it's like really really good
vegan Mexican food to where you do not
know the difference
really so yeah it's amazing you go man
some food you you you candied nay you
won't you won't know they're I mean
they're not healthy but like yes you
won't know the difference
yeah and go to preachers yeah but what
does it look like does a staff look like
preacher because I'm only eating the
food that is the weird thing when like
I'm an overweight waitress comes out as
life is the healthiest food around you
likely you're not anyway hope you'll eat
a lot of unhealthy food yes it's not
healthy to more yeah it's great super
healthy how many meals not 10 healthy
meals in two hours and it's great well
thanks for coming man we had a good time
yeah and if you can give Brad a ride
home on your motorcycle
I mean just know I have little tiny
koala arms I I will hug you
oh sorry I'm a the hands may creep
around a little no you know what I don't
know I'm not but you can hug me hard as
long as you don't get rads never again
right I never felt big entities feel
just like real titties by the way
there's a song for you a vegan titties
are better than regular titties
good night everybody
it's about last night